ahora vamos a crear los agujeros que nos
servirán para sostener nuestras baterías
y nuestras tarjetas controladoras
nuestra cámara y el controlador de el
motor en este momento estamos marcando
los agujeros para las baterías los
agujeros para las baterías y los motores
son para que pasen los cinchos a través
de ellos así que no tienen que ser
demasiado precisos aquí usamos una broca
de 6 milímetros y aceleramos el vídeo
para que vean cómo hacemos todos los
agujeros aquí estoy dibujando una línea
que une los agujeros de los motores y
las vamos a usar como punto de
referencia para alinear nuestras
tarjetas y cosas por el estilo
aquí dibujamos la otra línea aquí
tenemos nuestros componentes nuestra
cámara el controlador del motor y
nuestro arduino el anillo exterior y el
hexano abajo
vamos a encontrar una forma de acomodar
todas nuestras tarjetas para que quepan
juntas en nuestra estructura ponemos el
lexan en su lugar y ponemos las baterías
abajo nuestros motores están a los lados
y vamos a darnos una idea de cómo poner
los demás elementos aquí tenemos la
cámara que creo que podemos poner aquí
ya que tiene esquinas redondeadas que se
ajustan mejor a este borde ponemos el
arduino aquí para que su puerto usb
apunte al mismo lado que el puerto usb
de la cámara y quizá pongamos el
controlador del motor arriba de la
tarjeta de la cámara yo creo que es así
como colocaremos los componentes también
tenemos nuestro módulo de grabación y
reproducción que podemos comprar en una
tienda de electrónicos aún no veremos
dónde colocarla pero tenemos varias
opciones para ello por lo que de momento
la dejamos encima del arduino para
darnos una idea del espacio ahora
tomamos nuestro arduino y vamos a
alinearlo con las líneas del motor y
vamos a delinear lo
estas líneas nos ayudan a que no se
mueva cuando hagamos las marcas para
nuestros agujeros volteamos nuestro
lexan y por debajo vamos a marcar los
lugares de los agujeros para los
tornillos que sujetarán al arduino quizá
les parezca que no estamos marcando
justo en el lugar de los agujeros pero
eso es solo por el ángulo de la cámara
pero creerme que estamos haciendo las
marcas en donde corresponde es
importante que estas marcas se alineen
con precisión ya que los tornillos son
muy pequeños y los agujeros también
serán muy pequeños no como los agujeros
para los cinchos estos deben ser muy
precisos o no quedarán bien aquí pueden
ver nuestro tornillo es un tornillo para
metales 256 y los pueden conseguir en
tiendas de electrónicos es un tornillo
niquelado y queda bastante bien en los
agujeros del arduino y también en los de
la cámara así que no tendremos que hacer
nuevos agujeros pero necesitamos usar
una broca que sea ligeramente más grande
que él
ancho del tornillo que en este caso es
un dieciseisavo de pulgada o milímetro y
medio y ya que tenemos marcados los
lugares de los agujeros para nuestro
arduino vamos a perforar los quitamos
las rebabas de los agujeros y ahora
ponemos la tableta de nuestra cámara
nuevamente es importante que las marcas
queden justo encima de los agujeros de
la cámara así como los de arduino porque
los tornillos son muy pequeños usamos la
misma broca para hacer los agujeros de
la cámara colocamos nuestro arduino y
nuestra cámara para hacer otras marcas
en donde haremos agujeros para que pasen
los cables de los motores luego haremos
un agujero para nuestro interruptor de
encendido vamos a encontrar una
ubicación para esto
esto no es crítico podemos hacer estos
agujeros en diversos lugares
este es el agujero para nuestros cables
de energía y pondremos otros agujeros
para los cables para que podamos
colocarlos en diferentes lugares
finalmente marcamos cuál es el frente
del examen
aquí tenemos nuestro interruptor de
encendido y vamos a ver la longitud y
ancho del eje para ver si nuestra broca
tiene el mismo ancho para hacer un
agujero del tamaño adecuado en nuestro
lección y colocar el interruptor con
facilidad por lo que es muy importante
hacer los agujeros con precisión hacemos
el agujero para nuestro interruptor y
después terminaremos de hacer los demás
agujeros
así es como queda nuestro lexan después
de hacer todos los agujeros la
configuración de su lexan puede ser
ligeramente diferente de este si es que
ustedes deciden colocar los componentes
en otros lugares ahora vamos a conectar
nuestro election con el anillo de
poliestireno y vamos a usar los
tornillos originales de la lámpara de
toque para colocar nuestro lexan
revisamos de nuevo que los agujeros
coinciden con los de nuestros
componentes y ahora si colocamos los
tornillos
es importante no apretar demasiado los
tornillos contra el plástico suave
porque se puede barrer en los siguientes
vídeos veremos cómo colocar los
componentes